[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CLAIRE HALLORAN:
Today, we're going
to be doing goody bag
1, atoms and reactions.
Our objectives today
are to identify material
based on its properties, observe
a simple chemical reaction,
and identify the
limiting reagent,
and estimate the number
of atoms in a real object.
To do this goody bag, you'll
need vinegar, a plastic cup,
a ruler, metal samples of
aluminum, copper, iron,
magnesium, and tin,
but if you can only
get copper and magnesium,
it will work, and a pipette.
Some conceptual
questions to think about
while you're doing
this goody bag are,
how can we tell
different metals apart,
and how can we count atoms
that are too small to see?
First, we have five
samples of metal
that we would like to identify
using their properties.
The easiest to identify is
copper by its orange-ish color.
Next, we're going
to try to find out
which sample is iron by testing
how easy they are to bend.
Iron will be the most
difficult to bend.
So this sample bends very
easily just with my fingers,
so it must not be iron.
This sample is very
difficult. I can hardly
get it to bend at
all with my fingers,
and this sample also
bends fairly easily just
using my fingers.
So we know that this sample, the
hardest to bend, must be iron.
Next, we're going to try
to compare the density
of these different metals.
So this metal feels the
heaviest and most dense.
This one's feels
lighter, and this sample
feels light as well.
So we know that tin is
the most dense metal,
so this sample must be tin.
To identify which of
these samples is magnesium
and which of them
is aluminum, we're
going to test which one of
them reacts with vinegar.
So we're going to place
each of these samples
on the lid of our
plastic cup to make
sure we don't spill
any of the vinegar
and use our pipette to
put a drop of vinegar
on each of the samples,
and the one that reacts
will be magnesium, because
we know magnesium reacts
with vinegar watch closely.
It doesn't look like
we're getting any reaction
from this metal, so it
must be the aluminum
now, let's try the other.
You can see that this material's
forming tiny bubbles after we
put the vinegar on it,
so it must be magnesium.
Those bubbles are hydrogen gas.
Now, that the bubbling has
stopped on our magnesium,
we note that the
reaction is over.
There's still plenty
of magnesium left,
so this indicates that
the acetic acid inside
of the vinegar must be
the limiting reagent.
Finally, we want to
estimate how many atoms
are in our sample of copper.
To do so, we're
going to use a ruler.
Using our ruler, we can measure
the width and the height
of this copper sample.
So using the metric
side of our ruler,
we align the 0 with the
edge of our material
and see that it is about
13 millimeter wide and 25
millimeter long.
Today, we did goody bag 1.
We identified our metal
samples based on their material
properties, we observed
a simple reaction
and identified the
limiting reagent,
and we measured our copper to
estimate the number of atoms
in our sample.